-Our next guest is an
Emmy-nominated comedian
and actress who stars in the hit
series "Abbott Elementary."
The winter finale airs
this Wednesday on ABC,
with new episodes
returning January 4th.
Let's take a look.
-It's time
for the gift exchange.
Let's find out who's been
naughty and who's been nice.
And remember,
I only reward the naughty.
Everyone who picked a name
out of Mr. Johnson's ice skate
last week,
please gather 'round.
-Dorothy Hamill and I
used to be a thing.
This is all I have left of her.
-Okay, I hope you guys
all stuck to the $25 minimum.
-Um, I thought
that was a maximum.
-Stop limiting yourself.
Thinking small is
what's got you in a dead-end job
in a poorly run school.
-Can't argue with that.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Janelle James!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Now, Janelle,
I'm so happy you're here.
You are one of our favorite
kinds of returning guests,
because you were first here
in 2019 as a stand-up.
-Yes!
-You did five minutes with us.
-I did.
-I was not lucky enough
to have you even sitting
here next to me.
-Oh, my God.
I was so nervous there, too.
I'm looking at the picture.
That's my nervous hand
that's up like that.
[ Laughter ]
And now people yell at me
in Target,
so this is nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, we're so happy with
how everything's going for you.
Are you overwhelmed by it, or
does this make perfect sense?
-Uh, both.
-Yeah, I think that's right.
-Yeah.
-I think that's right.
-I was working towards it, but
it's still like, "Aah!
What's happening?"
So, yeah.
No, but it's all been great.
It's so good to be, like,
on something that seems to make
so many people so happy.
-Yeah, and it seems like
a show for so many people,
which is so nice
in this day and age.
You were at the Emmys.
The show was
very well represented
at the Emmys,
which was wonderful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was it your --
Was it your first Emmys?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
I mean, I think I had
a men's undershirt on in this.
Like, I've never
been to the Emmys.
I don't even know whose clothes
I have on right now.
But, yes,
my first time at the Emmys.
My first time being nominated.
And, yeah, it was wild.
-Did you -- You know,
sometimes the logistics
of the Emmys are an obstacle
course in their own right.
Did you make it in time?
-He know I was late.
That's why he brought that up.
[ Laughter ]
He knew I was late.
Yes. No,
I didn't make it in time, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm just curious.
I mean, I guess
if I could ask one question
out of the blue...
-I was late to my first Emmys.
I mean, it's a story now.
So, it's a story
that I get to tell.
But I wasn't the only one,
so that's all that matters.
-Yeah. It's not --
They make it very hard
to be on time at the Emmys.
-Yeah.
-I'm saying that genuinely.
But what about you --
Do you get to go to Hollywood
fancy parties now?
How is that treating you?
-I mean, I do get to go to --
I don't go to many,
and then when I do,
it's just a disaster
because I'm not --
I guess I'm not trained
to do the thing.
-That looks pretty good.
I feel like -- Do that.
Yeah, oh, I think,
don't sell yourself short.
I've seen a lot of high-powered
agents do exactly that.
-I practice in the mirror
ever since I embarrassed myself.
I went to the "GQ" party.
Were you there?
-No, I was not
at the "GQ" party, no.
[ Laughter ]
-I was. I was there.
I went to the "GQ" party,
and I saw Travis Barker.
-Uh-huh.
-The Blink-182 guy.
The reason I know who he is, is,
truly when I was getting ready,
earlier that day,
for the party,
I was watching a video of him
showing his home
with one of those Kardashians.
-Yeah.
-Right?
-He's famously with one of them.
-One of them.
Still don't know which one.
And --
[ Laughter ]
But the home was lovely, and
he seemed like such a nice guy.
Every piece in his house
had a meaning,
and it wasn't ostentatious.
It was really nice.
And I saw him at the party.
Yeah, I'm drunk. I was nervous.
But I saw him at the party,
and he walked by,
and I said, "Oh, my God,
I was just looking
in your house."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And that's --
That's why I stay home.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
How does a fella respond
when you say you were
just looking at his house?
-So, the Kardashian said,
"Okay," like that.
[ Laughter ]
They looked horrified.
He looked horrified.
-Yeah.
-And she said, "Okay."
And then they, like, walked off.
-Still hasn't really
narrowed it down for me
which one it is.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You -- One of the things --
obviously, we first met you here
as a stand-up.
That's this real solo art form
where you get to tell the story
entirely by yourself.
You know, you're just out there
totally by yourself.
-And I am myself.
-You get to be yourself,
exactly.
You get to choose what you say.
Obviously, this role
seems to be a perfect fit,
but it's also
a wonderful ensemble.
How have you found that shift
from, you know,
sort of being on your own to
being in a world full of --
-I work less.
-Yeah, you do. You do work less.
-When you're an ensemble,
it's not only about you.
So I get some time off,
where the story
focuses on other people
and the --
I just learned this thing
with the actors,
where actors say, "You're only
as good as your scene partner."
And so it's really good actors
on this show,
and it makes me step up
and have my [Bleep] together.
-And you guys all really do feel
like you've known each other.
-Truly.
-The show only works
if you only believe you've known
each other for a long time,
working together long time,
and it's just so natural.
-I think partly it's because
we're all cool people,
but also we started this show,
like, right out of quarantine.
We couldn't go nowhere.
Couldn't go anywhere
but work and hang out
with each other, you know.
We were the only safe people
that we knew at the time.
So it really made us closer
in a faster way,
having to do -- you know,
having to do it at that time.
-I've been lucky to talk
to some other cast members
of the show.
They were saying
the technical aspect
of the show,
the way you shoot, because
it's documentary style,
there's a real choreography
to every scene.
Do you feel like you're
getting better at that,
being able to know
the camera's coming?
-I mean, I thought I was good
from the beginning, so, um...
-Yeah, yeah.
I think everybody agrees.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm not --
-I guess my question is,
do you feel like your castmates
are catching up to your --
-To me?
Tyler got some work to do.
But, uh, yeah.
I feel like, because
I didn't know anything...
-Yeah.
-...I'm just doing it.
Until somebody
tells me otherwise,
I'm just gonna
keep doing what I'm doing.
-Well, I think
everybody here agrees
that that's
the best plan forward.
So nice to see you again.
-Yes!
-Thank you for being here.
-Thank you so much.
-You guys, that's Janelle James.
The winter finale
of "Abbott Elementary"
airs this Wednesday on ABC,
with new episodes returning
January 4th.
We'll be right back
with an incredible performance
of "Funny Girl."